this from the new york times criminal
charge is possible in shooting on alec
baldwin's set d.a says an inquiry into
how a cinematographer was killed with a
gun the actor was rehearsing with which
was not supposed to have live rounds in
it could take weeks
they said the santa fe county district
attorney said on tuesday that she was
not ruling out criminal charges in last
week's fatal shooting on a film set alec
baldwin was rehearsing with a gun that
he had been told did not contain live
emma when it went off killing the film
cinematographer so we know this now i've
got a few questions first let me just
read this quote
d.a mary carmack altwy says we haven't
ruled out anything everything at this
point including criminal charges is on
the table
i just i just want to point out the
entire time the story has been in the
news cycle alec baldwin has been given
every benefit of the doubt and it's been
wrong every time the first thing they
said was it was a blank and it was a
misfire
now then we learn from the union it
wasn't a blank but it was a misfire now
we're learning alec baldwin pulled the
trigger it wasn't a misfire
i i i you know i i think that's even
interesting too
was it negligent discharge or was it
alec baldwin intentionally discharging
the weapon that's why this starts to get
into criminal territory and there's also
a lot of people complaining about the
production cutting corners a lot of
staff saying that they were terrified
because the guns were going off
beforehand incorrectly
and and hearing you know misfire by the
mainstream media it doesn't tell the
story here at all so we're seeing a
concerted effort to try to murky the
waters already so at least at least
there should be an investigation here to
find out what really happened misfire
specifically means the gun didn't go off
so that's incredible negligence by the
media saying that yeah they were
obsessing about it it's like fully
semi-automatic yeah yeah they were
talking about
whether he intended to or not it was a
negligent discharge and i think it i
mean there were three people that i can
tell her involved hannah gutierrez reid
is the armorer who handed the weapon to
dave halls who was the assistant
director who handed the gun to alec and
told him it was cold wait
well this is according to this story
from latimes.com what i'm saying you
know i hear you yeah what i'm saying is
we've been told every step of the way
one thing and that only to find out
later that wasn't true right so one of
one of the details that i read was that
there were three different guns
and someone walked over and grabbed one
so i i kind of feel like him claiming he
told alec it was cold it's just them
covering you know their asses
i think this is from the director's
testimony they got a hold of the
director and they're like what happened
he's like dude i mean it's gruesome you
really want to hear about what happened
he the girl was paralyzed by the bullet
first couldn't feel her legs and then
she died it's it's absolutely horrible
negligent i mean you want to
this is
you know
for someone who lectures about how
dangerous firearms are he sure didn't
take this matter seriously uh well so i
i i kind of feel like manslaughter is
possible but you know when i was
bringing this up earlier charles you
were just like never going to happen no
i i well i mean you know the
look the the the calculus is ultimately
political it's like does the santa fe
prosecutor what what what are her
aspirations and does she want uh a media
trial just kind of navigating the media
trials suspect the answer is no a i
don't think i don't think the trial
happens that he would uh be convicted i
think the jurors can convict i think
he's too sympathetic and b i don't think
there's any interest in actually going
out and prosecuting the case yeah yeah
just from political perspective you know
i i don't know what happened i don't
think you know what happened i think we
can guess but but i think it is it is
unlikely nobody wants that heat nobody
wants the attention of a celebrity
murder case i think i think most people
hate him and you know people like alec
baldwin
he's kind of a jerk people like alec
baldwin not half the country does and
that's and that's the big issue when it
comes to issues like kyle rittenhouse
derek chauvin we know antifa will go
around and smash up windows and burn
down buildings and the right won't do
anything like that so there's already an
obvious you know it's it's a it's a it
flows in one direction the prosecutor's
gonna look at this and be like okay
let's say we do go after alec baldwin
we're gonna get a bunch of crazed you
know lefty types screaming in our faces
yelling at us and let's say we don't
prosecute him nothing happens yep okay
so which do we choose i think lady
justice is blind and if an actor
negligently discharges a weapon that he
should have inspected and kills someone
that a a manslaughter charge is is
warranted
well
let me read this from legal insurrection
this is where it gets interesting
because the dea is saying they could
have criminal charges and andrew bronco
we've had on the show before yes he's
got excellent analysis on the
rittenhouse case which we you know and
we'll talk about that case in a second
they say alec baldwin's situation
beginning to look a lot like
manslaughter the more we learn about the
fact of the case within the context of
new mexico criminal law the more this
shooting looks increasingly like a crime
specifically felony involuntary
manslaughter
he goes on to say the relevant facts
assumed to be established one that it
was alec baldwin who was manipulating
the gun that fired the projectile that
killed miss hutchins two but the gun
discharged because the trigger was
depressed by baldwin and not because of
some defect in the weapon
three the muzzle of the weapon was
directed towards miss hutchins by
baldwin when it was fired eg she was not
killed by an unpredictable ricochet
four the gun contained a live round the
bullet of which struck and killed miss
hutchins
five the ball that baldwin had the
opportunity to inspect the weapon of lot
for live ammo before he directed it at
miss hutchins and pressed the trigger
killing her and lastly
there was no justification for the
shooting of miss hutchins
now interestingly
some of these
recently are new developments such as
that he pulled the trigger that he
pointed at the woman and then he pulled
the trigger initially people were saying
misfire as if to claim that like i heard
one report they were like oh someone
pulled the hammer back and handed it to
him and then when he was holding it it
just went off like i said that's what
misfire meant no misfire means it didn't
shoot this was negligent discharge
the other the other relevant factors
which i've which i've stated but for the
context right now i'll say again
there's a witness who uh not a witness
but i guess you could say a character
witness someone who's worked with
baldwin says that they worked with him
in the past and he was always very
careful that was back in i think the 80s
or something that means alec baldwin has
decades of firearms training on set
he's a producer of the film there were
already
negligent discharges on the set that
crew had complained about so you can't
say he didn't know
then he was handed a weapon aimed at the
woman and pulled the trigger that sounds
like i mean
from from uh from a legal perspective
you're not a strong parent of reality
but but for me from a firearm safety
perspective the number one rule of even
a prop gun is that you don't point it at
somebody unless you're willing to pull
the trigger and uh as as you were saying
somebody who's so
uh aware of how dangerous firearms could
be this is it's like there was no reason
to put a prop gun at somebody who's
you're not actively using i don't know
if he's aware if he was aware i think
this would have been prevented he sure
preaches a lot a lot of this political
ideology against people who uh want to
have the right to defend themselves the
the the first rule of firearm handling
you know every every time uh one of one
of my foreign colleagues i got him
stephen katowski who now runs he runs a
gun news site called the reload um but
he's one of the one of the best firearm
reporters in america right now and
steven uh
took a bunch of his shooting at the nra
range which is a good time um and and
and the first thing that they tell you
everybody in that room is viscerally
aware of the importance of trigger this
plan of being wearing safety's on when
the safety's off where you're pointing
your gun only ever pointing the gun down
range if it's if it's loaded only ever
pointed down like these are you know if
you're if you genuinely lose a deadly
weapon or you believe it's a facsimile
of a deadly weapon you have to treat it
as such because it'll always be loaded
let's let's think about the absurdity of
the argument i keep hearing from people
defending alec baldwin just it's it's
the most insane thing ever i'm getting
all these tweets they're like clearly
tim has never been on set before and
they're saying things like tell me
you've never been on a movie set without
actually telling me about a movie set i
just want you to imagine
that you're on a movie set
and i've been on sets before uh i've
been on sets of tv shows and films and i
just want you to imagine you're working
you're a pa or whatever you're you got
you know look at the warner brothers
water tower and then all of a sudden you
see alec baldwin pull out a gun and
point it at you and you're gonna be like
this is totally fine it's hollywood
people point guns at everybody all the
time
there's nothing weird about this at all
no if if if that actually happened
people would be screaming and running
yet for some reason here
alec baldwin drew a gun pointed it shot
killed somebody
and they're acting like it's normal it's
not normal no it looks like they were in
the middle of a shot
the crazy word shot
uh they're in the middle of this this
take and they they got bad light so they
had to move the camera and it's like
momentary lapse of thought
i think that all three of these people
hannah gutierrez reid dave halls and
alec baldwin are all culpable for this
killing alex responsible all three of
them
deserve to be investigated in charge for
this the the the the the woman who was
the armorer
she made a mistake but she didn't put a
weapon in somebody she handed someone a
loaded gun so what so that's illegal she
didn't well she handed a a a
actually i don't think she even had the
weapon to somebody it was the assistant
director who picked the gun up and
handed it to baldwin okay so
she's got guns
and someone comes up and grabs one
i don't think necessarily that that
that's that's that's criminal it's her
job to have the weapons on set according
to the story they went to lunch and then
they came back and they just gave so
someone while they were away at lunch
the guns were unattended yep that's
that's the armorer's fault
yeah but i don't know if that's
like are you implying that while they're
away someone's snuck in and put a live
bullet it's possible you know
but in that case the person who put the
bullet in there is at fault definitely
well there's that's there's reports that
some of the staff were using the the gun
for
target practice even before that with
live ammunition so i mean this goes
along with the kind of narrative that
we've been hearing that they've been
cutting corners that they were just
trying to make sure that they produced
this movie as cheap as possible the
staff were protesting they were mad they
walked off sat for safety concerns
before this incident they walked offset
because of conditions that they said
weren't right on this movie set but alec
baldwin and the production staff still
continued and
i mean this is where we are right now we
have a story from fox news to say mark
how do you pronounce that gary ghost
famed lawyer says he'd be shocked if
involuntary manslaughter not brought in
baldwin rust shooting i got to be honest
i i agree with you i'd be shocked if
there are charges brought this is a guy
who is an establishment activist you
know she's really well loved though
and he has a lot of money in the legal
system here in the united states it
doesn't matter if you're right and wrong
it matters how much money you have it
matters what kind of lawyers you could
hire and he's going to hire a if if
there is charges he's going to hire the
best lawyers that they are that will
give him the best justice that he could
afford and he can afford a lot of it so
let's just be honest how the legal
system works here because a lot of times
it doesn't matter what happened a lot of
times it matters who you got on your
side and how much money so you think
he'll throw the blame on dave halls who
had it in the gun and said it was
unloaded i think there's many avenues
here i don't know
but there's many different avenues that
i see that i'm running with potentially
here i think uh
i think there's gonna no one's gonna get
in trouble for anything they're gonna
say it was an accident oh we're so sorry
he's gonna make a donation it'll all
just go away i'm not obsessed with
punishment i i definitely think that
throwing someone in jail isn't
necessarily the best way to make sure
they don't commit a crime again but i
definitely think this looks like a
manslaughter i agree like what would
jailing alec baldwin do to prevent him
from doing this again
i kind of feel like he won't do this
again you know but people want some kind
of emotional satisfaction well i mean
it's not just emotional satisfaction
right the the the justice systems
variety of functions but retribution is
not just about emotional satisfaction
with public it's about the fact that
there was a real harm done regardless of
intent and there has to be some response
to that the absence of the response is
harmful i'm trying to i'm trying to
forget yeah i'm trying to get over here
what the deal is with the district
attorney who's you know going to be
uh this attorney's offices are highly
politicized today in 2021 when they were
five ten years ago um it's she seems
like uh
she seems like a
career professional but you know
she has an enormous amount of power in
making these decisions it turns on it
turns on her uh essentially unlimited
discretion whether or not to break
charges you know actually you bring that
up it's actually really simple
is she a democrat or republican i she's
i i didn't look it up uh but she's santa
fe district attorney she's a democrat
she's elected then he's not going
anywhere yeah but what you sounds like
maybe you're implying that if nothing
happens if no charges come that actors
in the future won't really care if they
happen to also issue a negligent
discharge oh no i think they will i mean
i think
deterrence matters as well for
punishment right but like in this case
it's not about deterring alec baldwin
it's not about deterring other people
like alec baldwin's probably not going
to like go out and shoot a bunch of
people but it is about like the the
primary function just system in this
case is adjudicating to what extent the
person was harmed was harmed uh in a way
that violated the law and then if that's
true how they can uh
get responsibility for that harm yeah
well a civil suit is coming and alex
going to be paying out millions to the
family regardless of criminal
culpability alec baldwin is responsible
and it's remarkable how many stands for
baldwin can't accept that i'm a big fan
of his work in 30 rock you know jack
donaghy is one of the funniest
characters in a tv show 30 rock's
amazing you know and uh he's in
beetlejuice great good for him he's kind
of a bad person but i didn't separate
the art from the person thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you